hey guys we're back we're epic high and
i'm tableau dj
it's been a while right since we did uh
buzzfeed it's been a long time and you
know
buzzfeed
x
epic i collab is always always ahead and
then he goes
today we're going to do something really
fun but before we start we have to tell
you we have a new song out called face
id featuring getty boy ck justice the
music video is crazy it's on youtube if
you haven't seen it yet why go check it
out we also are doing a 2022 epic eye
north america tour you can get ticks
right now at epicy.com and today we're
doing epic kai
rank your songs
as you can see there are 32 songs that i
guess our fans like the most some of our
biggest hits and i've seen other kpop
artists do this but since we're epic hi
although we love all 32 of these songs i
mean we made them we care about them
very much we will try to decide
out of the 32 songs
which song
we hate the most okay which song
we like the least
okay
yes
[Laughter]
then before we begin as practice this is
your first born son
this is your daughter okay you have to
choose
which
of course you love them both and they're
both beautiful if you have to choose one
this is what we're doing today
favorite child
who is 51 out of 100 can you choose
see it's hard these songs are like our
kids we chose 32 of our kids we have to
decide which one we like
less so first our new song face id
versus oh my god born hater your face
why because it's the newest song
yes two cuts his favorite song is always
the latest song because that's the one
he's trying to make money with for two
cuts here it's just
money
one two three you say which one you like
less one two three four later
the song we just put out you like it
less face id
what do you mean it's a huge hit right
now
yes
jesus
versus lost one lost one is a song where
you know it's like a solo song almost
i don't think these guys will like it
that much
let me just tell you when don't hate me
first came out that was definitely our
least favorite song because
so many of our uh like core fans totally
shat on us
this album was very kind of poppy and
very happy which uh our core fans
apparently
you know don't like when the song came
out nitro is looking at like the
comments i see mithra's face just like
i'm like what is it and he's like you
don't want to see it
they hated us
but song became one of our biggest hits
ironically because the minute we uh
performed it live people were like oh my
god this is like undeniably
great uh to see live and it's now
always our encore song
and no thanks is a is a wonderful song
too it usually opens up our uh concert
which one do you like less
one two three no thanks
was produced by me rich was produced by
two cuts so this is a matter of like do
you like
two cuts more
or less happen ending rich which one do
you like less
yeah what the [ __ ]
happened
best friends forever with you but not
anymore
you're right i suck at making music
meant to soul versus people scare me
both produced by dj two cuts
but mostly uh the song was crappy before
we started
rapping on it it was the crappy song
like your beats
map the soul you like less
kill me
okay whatever let's do this side first
rain song versus rosario
[Music]
no but rosario also has like the music
video one two three
two to one yeah
okay eternal sunshine versus insole
eternal sunshine
was produced by suga of bts and me
insole was produced by two cuts and me
i'm gonna let you decide which song you
like less and if you choose eternal
sunshine that will probably mean that
you are
saying that you don't like bts
[Laughter]
they're totally different one two three
um
because we like them both this was a
very good song but love love love was
the song that like what did this made us
super popular fly
and one
i'm still getting more indian the song i
like less right
one two three one
i like fly a little more because it was
our first number one song it like kind
of put us on the map after years of
struggling burj
khalifa versus
one two
three
is actually one of my favorite songs i
ever wrote like lyrically but burj
khalifa is so fun like during concerts
man this is hard okay love story
featuring iu versus bleed one
come the regrets versus acceptance
backstory on here come the regrets we
made it with kanye west's team
at a song camp and they loved the song
so much they said that kanye was going
to take the song two cuts who made that
beat was so happy and ready to uh retire
and quit epikkai
and then the song never came out so we
put it on our album
[Laughter]
end of the world
versus fan fan and was one of our huge
mega hits
one two three end of the world okay love
drunk
versus home is far away
this is a crush versus or we have battle
like of the voices of the songs that
just like get to your heart
one two three love drunk oh umbrella
lesson zero lesson zero again is a solo
song
of mine one two three
of course based on a true story versus
eyes nose lips both very emotional songs
eyes nose lips which version though our
version right
that'd be pretty weird
okay
oh
again we are doing our least favorite
i'm all ready
this is really long let's go a little
faster born hater versus no thanks no
thanks no what
all right okay map the soul versus rain
sound the song we like less one two
three
in seoul versus encore
one two three
another contender last one or happy
ending which one you like less one two
three
lead or here come the regrets one two
three here come the regrets
we like both songs
except if we just have to choose one end
of the world versus love drug one two
three
less than zero versus eyes nose lips one
two three eyes no slips
no thank you versus rain song
the song we like less out of the two
one two three
[Laughter]
the song that lasts till the end we will
never perform again for the rest of our
lives lost one versus here come the
regrets one two three
why are you guys choosing all the songs
that i i'm like that that are so low
end of the world versus eyes nose lips
one two three
best friends
[Applause]
final four rain song lost one amor fatih
end of the world rain song
so many people tweeted me
saying if you perform a more fatigue
i'll go i like it if fans want it i will
perform this song
one two three
i have ready feeling this is gonna be
the battle
of two tableau solo songs lost one
versus end of the world one two three
oh that's a good point wait this is lost
one ah it's not less than zero i cancel
i cancel lost one
this is
produced by me
and they both feature nell's kim jong-un
he's able to keep it like i poured my
heart into both songs it's sad that
these two songs are the songs that you
guys hate the most but i'll leave it up
to you too to decide
both songs are hard both songs are hard
no but i like this song a lot i would
rather you chose lost one
as the one i hate one two three
one so the worst song epic has ever made
we will never perform lost one again for
the rest of our lives
i haven't released the solo album in
like 10 years
one day i will do a solo concert and i
will be performing lessons harold
eyes nose lips lost one amorphati
all these songs that i did on my own and
the guest is epikai pablo solo concert
featuring
guests two cuts and mithra jin i do
about three songs on my own and
everything else is epic high there you
have it lost one
is literally the worst song epikai has
ever made make sure you go check out
lost one on youtube and you'll realize
that even our worst song ever made
is a very very good song if you come to
our show march april 2022 you will
probably hear a lot of these songs but
not this one
roast
bye
[Music]
you